[Music]
it's a friday edition of p-f-t-o-t
the show into which we cram all of the
stuff that we can't get to
during pft live and we spent a lot of
time on friday morning talking about
that classic ram seahawks game from
thursday night and rightfully so but
other things that you need to know about
i want to start in minnesota it's been a
strange and awkward week for the vikings
they lost to the bears they couldn't run
the ball they couldn't throw the ball
and then after the game adam thielen had
some comments that were perceived
accurately to be a criticism of kirk
cousins then cousins apologizes to
thielen publicly and then stefan diggs
doesn't show up for work and then he
shows up for work and it gets worse
through it all i keep coming back to
a very fundamental question about the
vikings organization
who's in charge there
who really is in charge when you think
about
the best teams in the nfl
you know who's in charge instantly
patriots it's bill belichick steelers
it's mike tomlin
cowboys it's jerry jones there's that
one personality that stands out above
the others not that they run it by
themselves and not that they don't have
other voices to contend with but there's
one person who is there when something
needs to be handled that is the person
who you believe is going to be the one
who handles it so the vikings have a
problem now they have a problem with
their passing in their problem with
their quarterback their problem with
both of their starting receivers one
more so than the other with diggs
clearly wanting out
so who's the person
who fixes this
who's the person who makes the tough
decisions about what to do with stefan
diggs do you find him
for a no call no show on wednesday which
is what it apparently was
do you try to trade him you know the
thing is someone should have anticipated
this problem before it became a problem
then they could have traded digs with
greater leverage with greater bargaining
power because people just would have
thought ah you know they have
transformed their offense they really
don't need to have two high priced
receivers so they're trading one of them
no big deal now that he wants out
whatever you get now is going to be less
than what you would have gotten then and
the bottom line is as the vikings try to
navigate these issues they need
one person who is making these decisions
who is setting the team's agenda who is
it i don't know is it mike zimmer is it
rick spielman is it ownership see the
problem is ownership and look
the wolfs have done a phenomenal job of
giving the resources to the team that
they need to get the best players
they've got the best stadium they've got
the best practice facility but they're
not there they don't live there who's
the person who is there who's the person
who's running the show whoever that
person is
number one multiple problems have
emerged on your watch and number two
it's time to fix them
and it's time to make decisions
important decisions about the team and
just putting your head down and getting
back to work is not going to be the way
to solve this problem
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports